tu ferais quoi toi avec un million de
dollars monterey ma propre affaire
tu vois le genre pour traquer les
bandits et les prisonniers en fuite
suprême chasseur de primes missié un
truc dans le genre je les mettrai tout
son troquet [ __ ] que c'est bon non tu
n'as rien d'accord il d'avesnes tu as
fait il te faire un deuxième trou de
balle ouais c'est passé dans l'arrêt des
fouilles je crois qu'elle est juste moi
c'est pour la romaine dont les burnes
voilà
l'homme de ses rêves il va vivre avec
nous pour toujours
c'est comme si tu nous épouser toutes
les deux david moyes et maman david est
ce que tu as pensé à ce que tu comptais
faire pour sa lune de miel
ouais j'ai eu deux ou trois plans ce sur
moi j'essaie ce qu'il ne fera pas s'il
ne perd pas un peu de poids oui ça c'est
de la barre au chocolat
je m'appelle david guez je m'étais
toujours dit que j'étais destiné à de
grandes choses
ça n'avait pas marché comme prévu
jusqu'à ce que je rencontre mademoiselle
kelly campbell fait quoi avec un million
de dollars montrer ma petite affaire je
serai chasseur de primes souhaite je te
les mettrai tout sans toi au savon
mondiaux david fait moi voir ma pression
que la balle est passée juste dans la
raie des fesses oui je crois que la
longe et l'arrêt qu'elle m'a juste
effleuré lee kun hee lee m'a dit que
vous bossiez ensemble à la loomis
moi je dis que c'est une opportunité
incroyable
vous parlez de braquer une banque c'est
pas très difficile du charge la
camionnette
r et u mais les points se situe qu'à ce
prix importants papeterie son sommeil
ces autorités sont à la recherche de cet
homme des glissements quand j'ai
fabriqué pour toi 16 dollars et 78 cents
je suis le fils de jésus et de catwoman
17 millions qui manquent direct je sais
que vous êtes deux hommes qui font un
travail difficile
il est temps de dégager dalle ips games
de l'équipe tout cas que ça c'est moche
bon alors qu'ils vous voulez que je dise
pas maintenant pas croire c'est l'un des
deux mondes en vo chambre des garçons
tout à l'heure les enfants
guy forget
battus 4 à clermont tu voulais dire quoi
tiens bien ténue d'art
fois il faut savoir tout ait fonctionné
celle-là on l'a pas vue lundi